歡迎收看
最佛心幽默的財經節目
李才達人秀 我是李昭華
今天是星期五
這個禮拜漲了前四天
今天稍微止步囉
46000點沒有守住
小跌了210點
不過最近市場的氣氛
前是有回到太古來的
原因就在美國現在的升息預期
已經越降越低
包括CPI和昨天晚上的PPI的指數
都是低於市場的預期
或是符合市場預期
所以這導致美元也相較之下比較走弱
台幣今天強生有到一腳
所以今天外資又大買了台股400多億
連續兩天大買
是不是真的叫做外資要回頭
我們有提醒一件事
整個台股也許資金結構有所改變了
畢竟外資賣了那麼久
不過漲到46000點的附近
確實也可以看到
例如投信有一點停看停的味道泡出來
那很多的股票談到這邊
今天也叫做開高走低
似乎都在等待下個禮拜
一個新的佈局契機
所以我們今天要來幫大家全面檢驗
下個禮拜的策略佈局
好來歡迎今天三位來賓
第一位是盈利投資的中國中
中走
總總都有提醒指數來到45000點以上
就有可能慢慢慢慢的面臨到壓力
現在看起來果然是有一些
但是外資的回頭
會不會也形成一股新的資金勢力呢
等一下來好好拆解
台幣美元跟外資回流
到底有沒有要留意什麼
不過今天的話我們看到有一些法說
顯然變成法會
例如工業電腦的劃漢
但是研華龍頭確實創新高的路上
因此今天中大膽說
在這樣的局勢裡面
選擇被挫殺的IPC工業電腦
也會是一個安穩的好選擇
好 第二位是我們的國家級基金操盤手
黃豐凱 凱哥
凱哥也在看喔
這個投信確實有一些
卻不的狀況
甚至有一些好股票
明明之前他們好愛的
現在卻接連砍出
等一下凱哥有一個獨家清單
叫做投信的挫殺股
說挫殺要有理由要有證據
他會說投信不一定是真心想要賣這些股票
另外我們來看到
MACI調整台股的權重市三升
以及挪威主權基金也回來採買的話
有哪些外資看好的股票
等一下也一定告訴您囉
第三位是我們的籌碼增加權正小哥
前面講外資跟投信
小哥當然幫我們看主力和大戶
今天群聯法說會後
吃了一根將近9%的下跌
發生什麼事
單計賺118還不夠嗎
關鍵就在籌碼中
整個記憶體的狀況好壞不一樣喔
而大力光今天也是個回答
不過以CPO的代表來說
CPO的籌碼等一下一起幫您看
以及全陣波段大戶來了
來了小哥今天的獨門菜
等一下端上來
全陣大戶在買什麼
所以今天外資投信主力大戶
籌碼我們全部都幫您看喔
好 首先有請 鍾大膽
是
今天禮拜五
又下跌
等一下
你就是要禮拜五上漲
其他四天跌沒關係
但是這禮拜跟您做對了
前四天上漲
只有今天跌
但因為財壁今天強生
連續兩天外資都是大買
就等投信了
主流已經換人當了
但是我們看一下IPC
研發在創高
化汗今天吃了一根跌停板
是
我們看今天的市場上會這麼樣的強勢
或者甚至是在這個禮拜外之位那麼強勢
當然最主要還是有一些跟升息的部分
稍微趨緩的這個聲音出來
上次包括美國的CPI
這個跌超乎大家預期
那這次公佈了PPI 意外的持平
所以呢 兩個的物價指數
告訴大家通膨的壓力趨緩
那我們可以發現
他這次是低於期
然後這邊也是低於期
尤其也比上個月的數字來的低
那我們看我們台幣的部分
在這次當中也從32塊半
在今天盤中曾經閃見31
是 詳聲
那大概尾盤之後
還是受到32.046
換句話說
外資在這個禮拜的積極的買超
確實在台幣這部分
看到有個明顯的升值
所以如果正常來講
這個禮拜應該是骨粿
都是算是有利於投資人
是 那我們來看臺股的部分
在這個禮拜臺股的講
是量縮價漲
量縮價漲 這樣是好還是不好
坦白講 量縮價漲不要這麼好
這次的買盤 主要是法人的買盤
那投資人的參與度沒有那麼高
就一部分 收費量是四點六八兆
那我上次講過了
預估會一到兩個禮拜的時間
會反彈 上工
我上次講過了
那已經兩週了
上次提醒大家
好把握這次多頭的上工契機
兩個禮拜我覺得有把握
那第三個禮拜我就沒把握
因為呢
這次呢會上漲是雙i的效應
就cpi降
然後mzci升
助攻來到46500點的附近
那接下來就考驗什麼
真實力
我特別把它框起來
如果投資朋友
已經把整個今年這個大盤
從5月份這邊來看
46500點這個位置
收盤
收盤有在46500點以上的
各位 你看好像很多
只有三天
換句話說今天盤中最高的
要46400點 大家就很清楚了
開子已經接近到
真正的壓力區了
我各位認為說
4萬5可否順利上攻 站穩
你說現在不是已經達到4萬5千點以上嗎
坦白講 過去我們說技術分析有個叫做
百分之三的測試 什麼叫百分之三測試
就是說4萬5的3%以上
大概就是46350要站穩3天
換句話說 盤中曾經有來到4萬6千4
有來挑戰 但是終究我剛才提到過
46500點這個位置能夠站穩
到目前為止只有3天
換句話說要看三天
今天第四挑戰失敗還沒有
所以我覺得這部分是要去觀察
那上次的前波大量4.8218
就這個禮拜
各位看量也知道
黑這麼黑
那現在的量呢
目前來講只有4.68兆
這邊有7.75兆
所以換句話說
不容易馬上就攻上去
如果你要買的話
我個人認為是要等到
有拉回的時候
那當然另外一種有人說
會不會直接供上去
有 量如果放大
有兩種現象
第一 外置持續在大買
那排必車持續往31塊半
這樣子就有可能
這是第一種現象
第二種現象就是
接下來你就要常常看一個雲霄飛車了
像今天就有看到一些小雲霄飛車了
那所以我想
只有這種兩種行行
一種就是
外置就一次乾脆做到底
往上供 往上拉
另外一種就是大幅震道
開店已經來到90附近
相對上漲空間有限
也確實跟這個相呼應
那我上次有提到過了
這十年當中7月份如果下跌
8月份一定會出現跌升反彈
所以在這位置
我記得我上次送給大家四個字
大跌不賣
叫你買一定不會買
大跌不賣至少
把你抓住你沒有賣
那現在你要賣隨便你
但是怕你現在又想要進入
又捨不得賣
那我們之前看過的數字
就是7月份如果跌8月份反彈會上漲
但是他的漲幅不容易達到
前一個月的跌幅的一半
換句話說7月份跌幅6.51
現在目前8月份已經把它吃下
看起來8月份我認為後半個月
會有漲多的修正
大概這一波的轉折點
應該會在下個禮拜的8月19號
期貨即算前兩三天
應該留一下本波的轉折點
因為這波反導已經到了
轉折係數
以差不多也是三天左右
那中原點是這波的上櫃最強的
已經來到季線跟景線位置
那今天的上市沒有低於昨天的低點
但上櫃已經低於昨天的低點
所以我孩子強調
不管是就上櫃
或就上市來講
這個時候真的叫考驗生實力
這時候真的能夠上漲
就是主流股的主流
一種情況就是你找落後補長的
ok 那我們看一下美國的走勢
這波我認為是主要走跌升版談
是因為美國道勇指數最新創新高
但在這禮拜沒有創新高
反倒是科技股的往上走
換句話說這禮拜的反應叫做
對利率的敏感度的科技股
因為不升息
所以科技股走比較強
但是不要忘記
套球 籃球股這些
也是要跟利率有關
難道他們利率沒關嗎
換句話說多頭的格局沒有往上攻
然後這邊是跌升反彈
所以我覺得比較偏向是跌升反彈
這波大鵬認為不會一口氣往上攻
所以我想未來的部分
我認為主流骨可能會先休息一下
也抬了一段 包括像台積電
或老AOA這些
可能長多了稍微休息一下
接下來可能就是什麼
飛電或題材股
那包括像飛電就軍攻
今天的軍攻
那或題材的機器人的部分
類似這個部分
大家要接棒嘛 對不對
軍工的話
其實之前總總有提到
有時候市場主流再換
軍工會跑出來接棒
今天立院有通過一個無人機條例
等於不凍結了
所以今天的軍工大漲
可是延續性您覺得好不好
很好啊
我記得我上禮拜來講的時候
跟各位大家提到過了
總預算已經到了敏感奇了
這個在野黨要黨好像也不好
然後執政黨
這個預算沒過
他也很痛苦
兩個都有壓力啊
所以到時候一定會有一個協商版
果然是這禮拜真的有協商版
那因為他這邊已經沉澱一段時間
我個人是覺得比較有機會再做一個跌升盤
都一樣全部的純入的類股都走跌升盤
那現在目前比較主流股
就像除了低論記憶體外
那另外一個就是IPC
好 龍頭炎滑
像IPC 我今天為什麼會講IPC
因為說各位發現 IPC的炎滑今天是
雖然拉回
對 小壓回
坦白講 如果他這樣上漲
然後盤中的這樣變動的話
還所謂五日線表示什麼
它算是強
那因為它是龍頭類股
如果今天化汗跟它倒過來
那就不是這麼說法了
因為最主要是龍頭股是
目前還是多頭的格局
那其他類股
各股有一些部分影響的話
那就是要去做一個觀察
所以我想今天有包括一些
研華 化汗 四星科 飛捷 靈華這些
我看它的EPS
獲得外歐來部分
都算是有成長
而且本益比也都在20倍以下
那這個說研發比較大一點
那我們來看一下今天市場上
最關心就是化汗的部分
化汗吃了一根蝶蝶
我們想看前幾天公佈的財報
也不算難看
一PS7.15元
計幟有30% 也不錯
年增74% 創價歷史的次高
但因為零組件的漲價
所以他第二屆毛利蝶破20%
創下這四個季度的低點
但是還是比較去年同期的18.2
來得高
但本益比我大概算一算
其實今年有機會算23塊錢的話
其實本益比不到20倍
那下午今天剛好有法說會
昨天才報完
今天馬上為了他的股價報區
你看上半年一PS已經達到12.31
然後上下半年預估會45到55
其實換句話說
下半年的的成績應該更好
所以大概推算的話
其實跟我之前在預估也差不多
有那種可能性
那目前在手訂單
這個我們今天都講過
兩千五百五十億
那這個部分三大試驗會
實驗做一個發展
那並購這個
空儲嘛
這個德國的
大概預算會五塊錢
而且這個部分
會在明年的效應會開出現
所以如果你從他的
抽K線發現
紅 黑 紅
黑漆 黑漆
所以高等級就在盤整
那當然這邊
這邊是有一個大量
他這四根其實波動蠻大
對 漆漆漆
又回到原來漆漆點的位置
所以我更認為說
其實是毛利率沒有怎樣
其實他也回到原來的
其中一點的位置
所以我個人覺得
如果是你手中有的
不用太緊張
因為這邊也看有一樣
沒有 我倒是覺得可以
可以做一個買點的位置
因為都已經回到原來的
這個原點
換句話說
先前這邊的這個修正
可能有再反映到毛利率的部分
那我們今天就講
另外兩家公司
就講飛捷跟靈華
因為靈華講過了
那我們今天講這家公司是飛機的部分
那IPC我會再講出了
龍頭的研華往上創高之外
另外就是下禮拜有機器人長
那機器人長呢
飛機跟靈華
他們都剛好跟機器人有關
我們知道現在大家把重點都看在
這個上銀這些等等
比較算是大家馬上想像的機器人
但是這些也有一些機器人
也相關題材的部分
我們先從飛機來講
他這幾年呢
從原本的純硬體製造的部分
轉到軟硬體的這個智能方
所以現在就偏軟體跟AI服務的收入
看他的營收的走勢YY
也確實發現越來越好了
整個連征率也已經到目前有26%左右
第二劑EPS的部分也連征將近一倍
EPS3.4 創價單劑新高
各位看一下
他今年的上半年已經賺5.93
3516936.95.93
換句話說今年有機會賺
一個資本額非常高
因為他每一季
他通常可以賺到兩塊錢左右
那如果這樣的話
我們再看他的股息配發
今年配發五塊半
坦白講過去也算是高股息值
利率的部分
如果他發放
你可以到八成過去的配發的
這個去年的水準的話
那麼今年6月1PS
如果機會達到十塊的話
那八塊錢的股利
那股息值利率大概就將近有五%
那北一比大概就十五倍
我們來看一下這樣公司
蠻強勢的
如果不是今天的IPC
化汗有這樣下跌的話
坦白講
今天的IPC不容易出現
這樣大幅的一個走落不論
但是坦白講
他這邊已經突破前波的高點格局
而且這邊有大量贏過了
換句話說這邊也有大量
只是說今天真的是受到
整個市場上信心不足的問題
所以我跟你講覺得
如果是這樣的話
剛好拉回到前波的支撐位置
倒是可以去留意一下到後面的買翻
因為我剛剛提到過
如果他明年有機會配到八塊錢
坦白講 現在的殖利率已經不到
這個 已經殖利率已經有五趴以上
那另外一家是不是蓮華
那蓮華呢 之前跟輝達
已經在做合作了
那我們發現 確實 合作完之後
確實他營收 每個月營收
都是兩位數的高幅度成長
那目前的營收大概九十三億
那去年營收918億
我大運運關
他今年到9月份的時候
媒體應該就會報導
他的營收營超越整個去年全年的部分
那這家公司也確實已經有在做一個改變
因為運算模組化電腦
以及自動化的產品出貨同步成長
你可以發現
他的營利益 毛利率的部分
0.61 5.57 12.1
你會發現現在都是倍數在成長
換句話說他今年的上半年賺1.57
這部分有機會來超越先前的高點位置
法人運過甚至有機會挑戰七塊錢
這幾年當中最好成績
那本益比大概在20倍左右
他折率率大概目前是2.5左右
我們看一下他的走勢
他的走勢
就是有點
震盪比較大
不太像工業電腦
像這一波的時候
這一波其實長很急
大家都很意外
是啊
我覺得某種成績
某種在反映到他的成績
但因為這一波來講
他的低檔有大量
而且我記得有一天
他好像跌停板
在洗那個籌碼
然後這邊有一個大量
現在這個位置
在這個附近
所以我個人覺得
如果以剛剛講的
今年一批S有機會挑戰七塊
其實現在目前本益比
也差不多20倍左右
那現在就是變成
前波這邊有套老量
但是地檔也有一些大量
換句話說會俠服在這邊做整理
如果以這個位置來講的話
區間整理的話
這位置效果相對高
還是效果相對低
看頭這裡就很清楚了
其實這一波的話
反攻的量溫溫的
可是供應電腦以前冷冷的
現在反而他的量通通跑出來
代表市場有非常關注他們
這邊非常謝謝鐘總
謝謝趙豪
鐘大膽也提到這幾天
外資的回頭
確實給台股一股新的資金勢力
不過到46000點以上
也可以感受到
進入到前波套勞的深水區了
所以這邊要闖關的話
可能要補一些量能上來
以及要觀察主流的變化
群公股當然接下來
如果大家覺得市場資金輪動
他還是一個選擇
至於工業電腦很奇妙
最近的量能並沒有很大
可是工業電腦族群
量能卻是比以前明顯放大
代表市場把眼光認為
AI的棒子有交到這個族群上
趁著化汗上半年
意外的毛利率降低這件事情
這個族群又出現一個好的
契機跟買點提供給您
廣告回來 凱哥要上場拉
他要來講
最近有一些股票發現
投信不帶沒加持
還賣個不停
但是基本面也沒有問題
他說有一些叫做挫殺股
今天凱哥有獨家幫大家整理了一張說
之後投信非常可能回補
再來挪威主權基金
MACI到底在回補哪些股票
也一地幫你做解釋
這一週雖然是一個強力反彈的格局
但是到了今天市場上
有一點點觀望的味道出來
當然等一下凱克也要探討
我們有信心有底氣
在下週做佈局的
就是AI發展這件事情
完全完全不用去質疑他
但籌碼的動向我們來觀察
例如說投信這一波
有一些股票看都可以亂七八糟
所以今天有獨家的措殺股
要幫我們找出來
外資的話
像被動元件
或是有其他的類股
可以看見誰
是啊 其實這一波其實談得很快
但是其實有些人可能沒有撿到
這還是投信其實在這個反彈過程裡面
其實他們也是兵荒馬亂
因為之前被迫提損
然後馬上大盤又漲到這邊
又有點覺得大盤好像漲派動了
現在我們就這個氣小重大
氣小重大
那我們看國際市場
最近這個entropy就要掛牌了
這個台灣翻譯成安創培
聽起來很像要民
但他就是安創培
這家公司基本上
他的高階主管都是從OpenAI出來的
所以接下來公司是很會做算力
很會做算力
所以你看Google說
他要投資安創賠400億美元
然後做一個付買回
你看2000億美元的回購
因為他答應說
他要買5GW的TPU
然後在這個Amazon也要投資他331億
所以告訴你其實這個佔局
其實越開越大
所以之前前面有一段時間
大家在講這個NVIDIA的這個載農資計畫
這邊大家把AI算力
當作是一個可融資的商品
但其實這是有點風險
就是因為GPU這個東西
基本上它不是基建
不是基建 不是基礎建設
基礎建設可能10年 20年
它可以慢慢回收賺它的利率
可是GPU其實它跌價
尤其現在是美國不能賣
讓中國買到高階的GPU
所以它到時候萬一這個
下去是不是這個價格的部分
是不是造成很大的變化
所以你可以看到這個
揮達發布這個消息之後
股價是幾乎要創歷史新高
可是呢 高盛發布完之後
沒有上去
比如說融資要負責連帶的這個銀行
所以其實對他而言不見得是一個好消息
但是因為對美國市場來講
現在因為房地產裝備是很好
所以他們要另批新戰場
所以他們就選擇這一個 AI融資
而且我覺得對他們有個好處
就是他們可以看到很多公司未來的計劃
對 因為你要來跟我借錢
你一定有把你的Planetion告訴我
對 那很多公司其實
台灣也是這樣子
很多眷商其實都很早就看到
公司的籌資計畫 對
所以他們都知道
未來的幾年
公司會長成什麼樣子
所以很多眷商都在這裡面大賺特賺
所以我們投資人也要利用
公司在錯籌資的時候
看懂他們的公開說明書
這是一個MEGA
好 接下來我們來看的就是
為什麼說很多人怎麼樣
在這一波裡面
投信急急忙忙的下車
可是我們發覺有些公司其實沒有這麼的差
例如說他們在殺聯電 殺南茂
殺金居 殺曾鼎
我覺得他們好像有點殺錯了
他們還殺0050
對 就是他們其實就是很急著下車
因為這個盤讓他們有點嚇到了
就是過去一週啦 過去一週
好 過去一週
等於是台股在反彈
可是投信這些股票下車
對 就是我就說因為他們急著下車
所以有時候你很匆忙的要出國什麼
你會寄信幫忙帶一些東西
他也帶出了東西
或是拿東西沒帶
東西沒帶
那我再講說
這裡面其實特別是連電
連電特別是連電
為什麼 因為其實你看這幾天
其實像立基電愛卜都在漲
為什麼 因為他們都在漲細電容
細電容
但其實連電也是細電容的成員之一
滑棒電不是也是
滑棒電不是
不是
所以我覺得市場有點搞太清楚
是
就是目前以國內來講
會參與細電容的晶圓代工的
只有聯電跟利基電
所以市長常常講說
利基電是唯一一家
這也是不對的
但是這兩家的IP
都是從IP出來
所以IP應該是實質受惠
那你看他今天就
這今天的漲幅嘛
我不是自己講的
反正今天是漲的啦
好 今天漲的
其實你看這些被挫殺的股票啊
其實今天好像
除了像聯電是疊了以外
其實都沒有什麼疊
有沒有
可是今天盤不太好耶
對不對
對不對 那女生上應該是
投信把他殺下去
應該是要跟著往下殺
可是在今天這兩天
你發覺好像不是這樣子
好像你慢慢要上來了
那這邊還有個
跟著南亞同伯這個調漲報價的
金居 今天也跟著往上漲
我跟著往上漲
那記憶體不用講嘛
我上次講過
其實記憶體的顆粒還在漲價
顆粒還在漲價
他做到的封裝怎麼可能會差
一定也不會差嘛
所以你看他的七月業績
其實就很好
其實你說創個歷史新高
看起來趨勢還在往上走
所以我覺得南貓有點被挫折
而且他上半年就已經賺了快
兩塊多了吧
所以今年應該
大概mini碼就是接近五塊錢的水準
五塊錢的水準
現在九十一塊九其實也不貴啊
也不貴
再來就是真頂ky
我覺得其實他真的很倒楣
對 就是一直被這HDI版干擾到
對
但是我一直跟你講說不要看HDI版
大家要看ABF
對
因為前一陣子
這個長廣他就開個法說
他就說整個一個ABF的產業狀況
是從2025年一直隨到2026年
我是說衰了 倒楣
倒楣2026年
現在開始要脾氣太大了
是 他知道2028年
都看得非常的正面
而且他的產能供不應求
白板本來就在今年是夯的
對 所以南電隊已經要創新高了
你說曾鼎怎麼可能會在這個地方
被投信怎樣
把他埋沒了
所以我覺得投信有時候在殺股票
有時候殺得有點莫名其妙
我們一檔一檔來看
這次聯電
你第一檔含冤的
對 你看頭信其實怎麼樣
狂賣 可是人家在外資怎麼樣
狂買
藍叫含冤
人家外資是狂買
可是我們頭信平民狂賣
今天可能有些
今天沒有關係 在小調節沒有關係
好 換形態
形態當然這裡是有一個大量的壓力
在這裡沒有錯
可是這一段其實它也沒有什麼量
這也沒什麼量
所以我覺得它是反彈的格局
這是周K
我們開日K
你看一樣是這樣的形態
這樣的型態
我說他已經 這個景線位子已經站穩了
他現在就慢慢往上爬
所以我覺得他
應該也是會慢慢回去
慢慢回去
他可能也有被ETF調節啦
好 那我們來看一下
大家都講的立基電
立基電 這是立基電的日曆
你看他已經快要來到這裡了
對 會快要到這裡
而且他已經站上了日的大量低
日的大量低
外資很愛他
對 那我說假設立基電的細電容
是一個可以買的故事
那聯店當然也是一個可以買的故事
因為他就是有
他就是有
那當然因為他頭心不多
所以他們有被頭心砍殺
但聯店就是頭心很多
所以是被扎實
我們是拿來做對比的
對
所以我就說
如果你在看立基店
其實你也不要忘記
還有一檔聯店可以買
而且相對未接還比較便宜
還便宜
接著我們來看的就是
艾普
那這就是大家公認的
就是他其實就是有系電容
這是周K
周的大量低在這裡
周的大量高在這裡
所以他已經過周大量高了
他已經過大量高了
那這是日的形態
日的形態
基本上日的大量高就在這裡
所以也是站上
所以我覺得
細電容這個題材
確實是一個很明確的題材
因為未來是一名筆
會大量的產出
他們就需要細電容
所以我覺得找這個題材
做到明年我覺得都OK
因為這時間其實大家就找不到
未來的趨勢
因為大部分談到這邊
很多人覺得
都老故事啦
沒有什麼新東西
可是我剛剛講
像ABF
人家都跟你講說
好到2028年
之前凱哥在講
大家都不太相信
可是陸續
什麼南殿 景碩都出來講
看起來好像是真的
看起來是真的
所以我說
曾寧其實被殺了有無辜
等於是雖然老故事
但是現在看起來是惡度發育了
對 有這樣的
惡度成長
所以我們講說
氣電龍這個族群其實是可以把他包起來一起看
就我們剛才講的就是
南茂 機體風聲
那南茂頭巾還在殺
這砍得好兇啊
頭巾還在殺
這一比八千多張
但我覺得啦
當然就是說
因為這裡有一個大量低被殺下來了
那他也談了一段到這裡了
到這裡了
但我覺得他應該也是屬於被措殺
因為我說第一個是業績真的是好的
因為他七月零收是創一個新高
然後EPS也是在往上的增加
那我們要看到
整個一個南亞科的一個狀況
南亞科
對 所以告訴你說
目前看起來肌體風裝
不會有什麼太大的疑慮
那只要南亞科往上
它就會跟著往上
那我們就看是金居
金居 金居其實你看
頭心開始怎麼樣
開始回來
這兩天終於恢補
之前賣了一萬多張
那我覺得這可能也跟今天這個
南亞科同伯報價上場有關係
大量在這裡
是 對
所以我覺得他們也殺得差不多了
今天同伯類都好厲害
對 殺得差不多 對
但是這地方看起來有一點點
還是有點虛啦
還是有點虛
不過我覺得也是會跟著往上走
因為其實他的
不管是目前的四五
基本上這兩個規格
都已經在交貨中
而且他還在擴三期廠
在雲林要擴他一個三期的產能出來
而且我那天有特別去看了一下
這個日本的這個三井
他說他到二零二八年
要大幅的增加 AI 的同伯
表示什麼
表示同伯虛虛
真的很強
所以我覺得這可能被挫殺
接著就是增典
我們剛剛曾敏琪幫他講過
就ABF 真的是好啦
所以你不要一直看他的 HDi
所以你就把它
沒有看了
而且他給你很好的位階去買
因為你像什麼男店
景色都已經快要到這個位置
星星也站上一千以上
都在這個位置
我覺得他相對是一個好的買點
好的買點
而且你看外資投信也開始同步了
已經變成同買
所以我們在這個裡面開始
從貝克裡面找珍珠
就是說不要覺得這時間是沒有辦法買的
還是可以有好的股票可以讓你買
只是你就是多花一點時間去找
好那我們接下來講就是說
不管是MACI或挪威主權基金
其實都有買被動員件
目前談了一些了
對但是其實我必須講
就是挪威主研基金
其實他比較像是退休基金
對
所以他買了股票
理論上是趨勢
他是買趨勢的股票
他不是買高股息的概念
他是趨勢的概念
可是他是一個退休基金
所以他是要買比較長線
至少是長線部件
所以你看他的錢時大
一定都是耳熟能詳的標的
台積電啦
對 都是大的
紅海啊
但是能夠被他選進去
基本上一定也有他的理由
但是他比較特殊
因為他沒有基金
經理人直接在handle這個股票
那他就有決定
所以他其實是有點偽台灣的
對 難怪他有買
我記得好像日電帽還是什麼
對 他就是偽託給台灣的基金公司
但是這是一部分
一部分
所以我覺得你可以多觀察他的股票
就是說他除了十大以外
會去買的股票
通常都是有一定的nitch
會有一定的故事
所以大家會覺得說
為什麼他們國劇就不用講
為什麼跑去買核酸糖
對 那其實我們核酸糖就講過
因為它是這個AI裡面的
MLCC的存量是比較高的
存量比較高的
那我們也講說
你可以透過核酸糖的股價
去模擬操作國劇的股價
我們之前有好幾個分析師來
都一直在講說國劇華清格
我們就講說
你先看他再來操作這兩檔
會比較風險會比較低
我今天被動是回的比較明顯
今天排名上比較沒有被動的消息
對
那你用就純度來講
他是比較高
是
那你說要
他要取代他
我覺得不太容易
不太容易
因為產品的特性
產品的特性
我們來看一下喜太
你看這是國具
你看投信也還在買
所以他這邊的下殺
某種程度我覺得
就是他第二季的EPS
其實並不特別的亮麗
不特別亮麗
所以看起來他是有一點點壓力在這裡
但是也還沒到
你看你把這一根跟這一根抓起來
有沒有
這一根這一根抓起來
你就發覺其實他還有一段距離
還沒有滿足
反而看到外資對他
賣的時候也是蠻兇狠的
是投信在挺他
因為我們看到其實大部分的ETF投信
都有他
那何生長之前講過
因為他這一段是因為被處置的關係
所以這一段是殺得莫名其妙
雖然很多人死在這裡
最後被砍出來
所以這一段
他算談得強的
這一段相對來講就是真空
對 真空
用真空來形容
所以他回到這裡
基本上這裡整理完
應該還會再往上走
至於他能不能過這裡
我覺得就再看看
不過我個人覺得
目前投信在買
而且整個第三季
其實他們的報價
確實還有往上走的空間
因為包括日本也在講說
這報價還要再調漲
所以我覺得你可以先看核酸糖
再來操作的國具
應該會是比較好的操作
也等於剛剛講到核酸糖
一直把它列為是被動元件的領頭
是因為它的 AI 純度
我覺得這個大家也可以去思量這件事情
這邊非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙華
因為凱哥自己就是操盤手出身
帶過投信
他說投信其實有很多的內規
前一波有可能為什麼邊談投信邊砍
不見得不看好
是有一些停損的部位
或是ETF的換股等等的
比如先把它出清掉
出清後又不見得
馬上買回來就形成了
股價有被挫殺的問題
而剛剛有各自點出
他認為的挫殺名單
將來看好的理由跟原因
這邊值得您參考
而被動物元件
投信倒是滿愛他們的
但是裡面純度最高的
我們首看和升堂
而大哥國巨
外資能否停止賣他
也會是一個觀察指標
這邊提供給您了
廣告回來
小哥要上場了
小哥也來幫我們拆解
為什麼昨天去年開法
說這麼好的成績
今天卻吃了一根
幾乎要疊停
相關的記憶體
還有CPU的籌碼
以及波段權政大戶
等一下小哥
一次告訴你
主力在做什麼
前面講了不少
外資跟投信的想法
那今天小哥來自然要告訴我們業內主力
這一波有受傷
那急著談上來
也會想要趕快來回血
還有處置骨的調整
大家都知道以前小哥喜歡處置骨
現在20分鐘沒了
只能兩分鐘
那要做什麼呢
接下來請教哥了
現在只剩兩分鐘
只剩兩分鐘可以玩
太短了
對啊
可是你喜歡短
我喜歡短
不過這個說好
其實周轉力變快了
是
因為平常還要等20分鐘
以前我們玩處置
這個盤中都有時間去上個廁所
是
現在都要包尿布了
好
等一下也會順帶來分享
因為最近有一些公司被關
但是兩分鐘我們怎麼判斷
全聯昨天
對
法說明明財報一季118塊的EPS
結果今天直接送他9%的下跌
那大力光今天也是回檔
可是你覺得他籌碼是不錯的
以及等一下幫我們看全陣大戶
嗯好
首先我們先來看這個群聯
怎麼了啦
那群聯其實我覺得最
最重要的問題就是在這裡
是
第三季這個內的漲幅
出來到一到兩成
毛利率將降至56.7%
那這個前面都很好
但是股市是看未來的
對
那第二季呢
他的毛利率很高65.3%
上半年又63.8%
但是第三季會下降
這個很多像一些眷商
然後就富邦
就下降不了這樣
直接下修
其實未來還是比較重要
好 這是市場殘忍的地方
賺了這麼多錢
因為其實潘董有講一件事
毛利率再高上去
全市場都會受不了
這個是事實
則對他們自己不利
對啊 因為他聽完這句話
富邦就下修他了
對
所以這邊呢
這個股市一樣
這個之前的成績再怎麼好
未來有點擔心就會下修
那尤其其實他們這波上來也漲很多的
漲蠻多的股價就比較容易修正一下
好 那我們先來看大立光
CPU的代表
對 大立光絕代CPU台積電力挺
9月份要部件手條是動畫
是這個市產線
所以看起來是蠻有未來的
那昨天秒田席今天有稍微修正一點
那我對大立光未來的看法
還是蠻樂觀的
我們就來看一下一個代表記憶體
一個代表CPO
對 好 那這個
來看一下 群聯
那群聯呢 各位看到
他這陣子從低點上來
是有反彈的
其實也反彈蠻多的
對 也反彈了
那像這種從下通道的反彈
來到上通道
通常會有點壓力
是
對對對
因為這個是統計學上的壓力
是
因為他這個布林通道呢
還算這個平
所以本來就預壓了
對 本來就預壓了
那預壓了剛好又遇到這個事件
所以修正一下我覺得OK的
是
那大立光呢 在這個位置
他在 它跟群年一樣
有點在這個上通道的位置
不過對群年而言
因為貸寬太寬了
所以他壓力比較大
這邊也要幫大家解釋
因為貸寬寬
他可能就會變成來回正
可是大立光貸寬窄
他就有機會稍微窄一點
比較能力突破
但這個稍微窄
跟一般股票比起來也很寬的
也很寬
也到30幾%了
這群人比較誇張
那最近他的籌碼也稍微變好一點
投信
投信最近是不離不棄
是喜歡他的
買蠻多的
所以大立光我看起來
只要他有拉回修正
都是不錯買點
兩檔比起來
可能大立光回檔也會比較勇敢
是比較勇敢一點
好
接下來看這個
這些主角
南亞南電聯貿臺光電
稍微排講這樣的原因是
同一個族群就是同伯類
因為南亞今天有宣布
他的同伯類的材料要再漲價兩成
兩成
然後所以南電這個載板
然後聯貿臺光電是CCL
臺光電很猛
很猛
接近625年的歷史新高了
而且他前波跌的
前波跌的時候
他不算跌太深了
他這個前波從高檔跌下來
大概跌30幾%而已
當然不算跌太深
6字頭 好歹算3字頭
其實30幾%真的算跌少的
因為像被動都跌70%
可是他是大龍頭
那這波反彈過來
蠻厲害的 其實離錢高不遠了
不遠不遠
所以這個臺灣電
這個即便前波主力有災脈
但最近這個籌碼相對安定
一下子就漲回來
他盤中差50塊而已
差50塊而已
所以其實創高是有機會的
那我們來看藍牙
藍牙也是一樣
從前波跌下來
那這波也反彈蠻多的
所以這些股票藍店也是一樣
他是強的 都強
這四檔都強
這四檔最強的是聯帽
對 這個不只過前高創高了
是 那而且他還怎麼樣
他被處置囉
這聯帽連續兩次處置
但這兩次處置都是兩分鐘
那這次的兩分鐘處置
這個新的措施
那新的措施
他只是把時間變短而已
但是整個該圈存的還是得圈存
所以我們這樣看起來
統計上他還是有賣壓
但是聯貿就非常厲害
即便遇到兩分鐘的再次處置
他看起來沒什麼賣壓
那像這種看起來沒什麼賣壓
他再漲下去
他又可能會處置不完
資色的組織不然是兩分兩分
會不會影響沒那麼大
因為一直都兩分鐘
那我覺得阻力
對阻力而言
因為其實再次組織了兩分鐘
他整個量還是會縮
因為你就是要圈存
你就是要先繳錢
才能買股票
所以這種我覺得短線上
他還是會有壓力下來
那這幾檔都是一樣的
都是從低檔反彈要靠近前高
那靠近前高你就要特別留意
因為靠近錢高一定有之前的套老賣壓
所以靠近錢高有套老賣壓
你不如等他拉回再買比較安全一點
但是籌碼上來看
這四檔都還是OK的
從來看都還是OK
這主力都有買
聯貿買得最多
聯貿買最多
所以他最強
因為這些大家可以回頭去看
7月8號跟6月26號這兩機
都是籌碼好才推的
也安然的
在這波谷在中重新復活
重新復活
因為這種談起來已經快漸漸全高
算是很厲害的波調
你看最近被那種談那麼多
可是離全高還是很遠
還沒有
還是很遠
那我們從現在看
這個群聯法說變法會
是真的
那就導致這個記憶體
他今天的這個掌碟互線
不過比較多的是這個碟
碟比較多
那這個記憶體類果
其實他們前波都漲很多
去年記憶體漲最多
記憶體漲最多也漲最早
漲最多漲最早的最先修正
修正完之後也最早反彈
最近記憶體也開始在彈了
南亞哥有創高了 有代表
那這些呢
他們的前半段
他的主力綽緩都還不錯
大概切到胃肝嗎
跳跳胃肝
但是胃肝有點弱
對 胃肝因為只剩
主食吃的飾
那這個威剛以上的充滿都不錯
威剛以下的充滿比較差一點
所以大家來看南亞科
大哥南亞科
創高了
而且有那支出報高是1000塊
對
但是呢
他這個創高
各位看
創高的充滿是蠻漂亮的
這個主力看起來是聯買
但是這種聯買呢
他也沒有說
這個買的很多
都買的時候會休息一下
買的時候休息一下
所以這種呢
他可能就是慢慢慢慢
這句詞狀的慢慢長上去
所以這種還是一樣
今天是買黑不買紅
買黑不買紅
對 因為到了上通道
他的壓力比較多
買黑的心情
可能會比較安定一點
因為當你最高隔天又殺低了
哇 這個你可能又要想天水
但籌碼是好的
說完不錯
好籌碼
每次買都大買
這調節一點點
是 好
所以南亞克這麼看
好 所以有好的籌碼
我們就可以買黑不買紅
是的 好 來看下一個
下一個預創 我這太強了
因為剛剛哥還問我說
他到底是
我說因為他做什麼他都有
像今天長軍功
搞不好他也可以說他有
因為他以前有做過無人機
真的很厲害
那這個而且你看
他第一檔說要實庫長谷
一時事 你看他在
這個不知道是消息是提早之後
怎樣 前一天是跳空漲停
可能跟那個 跟當時的盤是有關
是
那後面呢 一時四晚
哇 一路攻上去
一路攻上去呢
他也一直都有面臨處置的問題
有面臨處置問題呢
他還繼續漲
對
非常厲害
那怎麼辦
現在單兵如何處置
你看他帶款已經全部打開了
然後他也在往上攻
還是往上攻
但是我們來看一下
他的主力呢
因為處置的關係
主力呢
就沒有買像之前這麼多
這麼多
所以呢
這種處置下去
他也會連續處置
是
所以連續處置的股票
我們都是等他
因為處置拉回
因為處置拉回那個點
會是一個很好的買點
接下來看基隆科
他是創歷史新高的股票
那基隆科也是一樣
他跟預創很像
他的主力也是連買
但基隆科最近的這個
黑K比較多
因為這個處置關係
買盤有點不計
所以也是一樣
只要他有回檔
都是很好的買點
一樣也是浪子回頭
因為他們月線應該都是上揚的
是 好 叫這個也可以留意
來看下一個 華邦電
那華邦電他的籌碼就比較差了
為什麼這樣
那我們來看 華邦電的主力
是沿途一路賣的
所以他跟南亞克比起來
就相對落比較多
他都沒有創高
奇怪 兩家本來一起放在一起比的
這次怎麼差距拉得那麼遠
所以我覺得是籌碼的關係
那一到這個位置
這個位置是布林通道的平行上通道
對
到平均上通道本來就有壓力
然後他主力呈現賣超販壓力更大
所以華邦店這種股票
只要來到上通道我都建議你
這個有獲利的趕快先賣一些
好
雖然剛剛看到預創金卡爾科
比較右上角
但他比較符合浪子回頭
華邦店看起來比較沒有漲
可惜抽賣也不好
也不好
像這種平均上通道
大概就得也賣了
是
好
這個接下來看這個CPU
因為有一堆被關緊閉
華興光聯軍這個訊息
他們很猛 之前先疊
我還現在這次先長
又長到都被關
對啊 前陣子有的是疊很多被關
現在是長很多被關
那這幾個看起來
前面的籌碼看起來還不錯
那今天的疊幅都還蠻大的
對 都還蠻大的
我們來看華興光
好 華興光
那華興光你看
前波這樣子疊很深
低點升到這個平均下通道之後
這邊開始起漲
這邊是疊得有點多
後面進處置
最近又漲多進處置
所以這種漲多進處置
他最近有一個
浪子回頭機會
也是浪子回頭
所以下禮拜華星光角有機會
浪子回頭各位可以考慮一下買點
而且投信蠻喜歡他的
最近投信有賣
投信大買
對 蠻喜歡
現在看下一個 聯軍
連軍也一樣 連軍也是處置
這個處置只要有回檔
不過這種平行通道的回檔
下通道會是一個很好的買點
要到下通道
對 下通道
好 接下來我們看這個
台新科
混入了一檔 其實算封測
但是應該也有做到CPU相關
台新科當然從而比較好一點
所以這個最近一樣
這是一個平行的通道
平行通道 下通道是比較適合買
那上通道 你看
所以一到上通道就有壓力
所以上通道呢
你可以考慮賣掉一些
做一個盤整區間操作
好 會比較好
封測業績都是好的
雖然混在CBL裡面
但是只要以封測來說
EPS跟本益比都是相對好的
那最後呢 我們來看這個
波段犬證 在做什麼呢
那波段犬證最近呢
他的名單呢 沒有大幅的更新
最近這個有波段
我們還持續追蹤的
那比較好的籌碼是
是保瑞跟松川金秘
還有新的
這三個是比較好的
但是好像沒有很強力
保瑞倒是給的蠻強力
可是保瑞的股價
股價就一直躺在這邊
你看冠軍人家還付的
不如說要花藥
保瑞真的好辛苦
真的
那我們來看另外兩檔
所以決定放過保瑞
先來看松川金秘
來看松川金秘
上次在這邊講之後有漲一波
然後後來遇到了
7月份的大盤大修正
整個跌下來
這講完之後其實還漲蠻多的
7月份大修正他也跟著修正
不過最近又快創新高了
所以這個孫安金明各位也可以留意一下
那最後看這個星雲
設備類股
對 星雲是南藤哥
南藤哥高檔也買 高檔買
然後薩蒂大福的加碼
所以未來看起來也是有機會
好 他這個有可能前面已經自動歸零嗎
還沒有 還沒有
還沒到歸零
好 設備股也是業績非常有保障的
這邊非常謝謝小哥
謝謝
還記得上市小哥來
是幫我們分享地板股
沒想到短短的兩週之後呢
他已經變成主力在找機會要上車了
因為有一些股票
有一些族群例如像ABF在辦
雖然很好
可是主力會覺得到這邊
要再買的話有點吃力
會產生一個所謂的類股輪動
像剛剛講的不管CPO
或是記憶體
或是波段權政大戶等等的
他們會去找還有肉的
所以現階段
觀察籌碼變得非常重要
因為統一族群
可能籌碼會兩極化喔
主力也急著想在這一波回來上車
所以我們散問朋友
看清楚就好囉
好 今天是星期五的晚上
非常謝謝Savage的
沒來到現場
這個禮拜是一個反彈週
也會讓不少人
可能產生了一點點
FORMOR的情緒但不用
我們有發現
頭線也在回補啊
主力大會也在找標的啊
大家都是在一個水平線上面
各評本是為我們參考這些資訊的話
下個禮拜的佈局方向其實就很清楚喔
也希望今天的理財展安秀
對您投資有幫助
下週再會囉 掰掰